>> Oh, my God,
Stevie's on WWE!
Oh!
I can't believe it!
Stevie's on there!
What?
Free!
Yeah, off the cuffs of Sting.
I cannot believe this!
Oh, my God.
Stevie!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Charlie just tried to hit him.
Oh, my gosh.
He's beating up Triple H.
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, he's about to give him
the Scorpion Death Drop.
Oh!
Ahh, yeah!
>> Hopefully he's on the phone
with his therapist.
Pro wrestling is like the
Beatles.
The good ones are dead.
That super flamboyant wrestling
nerd is Chris,
and he's obsessed with Sting.
If you don't watch this show
with the same passion,
you are not a fan.
I grew up loving wrestling too,
but then I dialed it back
a bit because I wanted
to become successful.
The pageantry, the face paint,
the crushing sadness
of a washed-up wrestler with a
crippling pill addiction and
five kids that won't
speak to him--I loved it all.
Sting has been a pro
for 30 years.
If Michael Jordan had that
kind of dedication,
he'd still be in the NBA
doing what he did best--
blowing point spreads to keep
bookies from hurting his family.
I miss the days when wrestlers
could be fat,
unhealthy beasts like
King Kong Bundy and Jim Ross.
Part of the charm was
the fact they could drop dead
at any minute.
Real or fake has
never been the issue.
How can you say the UFC
is a better product when
their biggest star is a girl?
Not her.
The UFC is a joke.
I want my athletes in thigh-high
boots and with decades worth of
backstory; not a bunch of
crossfitters who use
their actual names.
"In the octagon, it's
Matthew O'Connor from Rochester,
New York.
His mom was a teacher!"
Who gives a crap?
I respect Chris for being a
grown man who has the balls
to care about something
so childish.
That's why I flew him to L.A.,
where everyone is too cool
to admit they like anything,
in this week's Web Redemption.
Oh, my gosh!
She just put an inspirational
quote on the wall!
And now she's hanging a giant
clock!
I can't believe it!
Ahh!
>> Hello?
>> Come on in.
Thanks for coming to my
farmhouse.
I'm just watching a new episode
of Fixer Upper.
JoJo puts Chevron on everything.
Oh, my God!
I want to eat her butthole!
Where you from?
>> Tennessee.
>> You special needs?
>> [laughs]
>> I'll take that as a "Yes."
>> No.
>> Okay, no.
I didn't want to say anything
insulting, and it turns out,
like, oh, this guy's got
problems and wrestling's the
only way that gives him a little
bit of happiness.
>> No, not special needs.
>> You love wrestling.
>> Love it.
>> Who's your favorite wrestler
of all time?
>> Sting.
The man, the myth, the legend.
>> How mad were you at the
outcome of Hogan vs. Sting,
Starrcade '97?
>> Sting won.
It doesn't matter if Nick
Patrick, the referee, had been
knocked out.
He was the NWO referee.
He was cheating anyway.
So why care if Bret Hart comes
in there?
He was a referee earlier in the
night for Eric Bischoff versus
Larry Zbyszko, so why not just
let him be the referee for that
match at the end.
I was pissed.
>> Do you see this smirk on my
face?
>> Yes.
>> That's me realizing that I'm
talking to an insane person.
You're like the Rain Man of
wrestling.
>> That's not the first time
I've heard that.
I can't believe it!
Ahh!
>> Who are you talking to on the
phone?
>> My mom.
>> Why don't you just go
upstairs and talk to her?
>> Because I live with my
fianc.
>> What?
All right, hold on.
My head can only explode so many
times.
So you're not gay?
>> No.
>> You mean to tell me you
weren't in your parents'
basement?
>> Yes.
>> Favorite wrestling memory?
>> That I've seen in person or
that I've seen on television?
>> Sure.
>> Which one?
>> I don't care.
>> It would have to be Sting
coming down from the rafters for
the very first time.
>> You didn't see that coming,
did you?
>> No.
>> Who's your favorite
old-school wrestler?
>> Sting.
>> Okay.
>> Sting's been around my entire
life.
>> Do you like the Four
Horsemen?
>> Oh, love the Four Horsemen.
>> Oh, don't put those four
fingers up in this household.
So help me.
That's eight.
That's not gonna affect me.
You think you could break out of
the Scorpion Deathlock?
>> Oh, I absolutely know how to
do it.
I've put it on other people
before.
>> But can you break out of it?
>> Yes, I can.
>> Huh.
>> You want to put me in it?
>> Kind of want to.
>> Let's go.
>> I don't think your fianc is
gonna like you rolling around on
the floor with another man.
What wrestler do you hate the
most?
>> Brock Lesnar.
>> Chris Benoit.
>> Why do you hate him?
>> I mean, just 'cause he killed
his family.
>> Oh.
>> Seems like a bad dude.
Did you see Hulk Hogan's sex
tape?
>> Why would you watch a Hulk
Hogan sex tape?
>> 'Cause I want to see Hulk
Hogan have sex.
It's just funny.
I wanted to see if when he put a
condom on, his penis ripped it
off.
All right, I got a huge surprise
for you.
It is right outside that door.
I don't want you losing your
mind.
>> Don't mess with me.
>> I don't want you--I want you
to act normal around him.
You're about to meet the one and
only, Steve "The Sting" Borden!
>> Oh, my--oh, my God!
>> Oh, yeah!
Snap into a Slim Jim!
>> Sting's not black.
>> Sting's not real.
>> I told you this wouldn't
work.
>> Don't beat yourself up,
Sting.
I tell you who I'd like to
meet--Mr. Perfect.
>> He's dead.
>> Ah, not so perfect, is he?
How about Yokozuna?
>> Dead.
>> Really?
>> Yes.
>> British Bulldogs.
>> Dead.
>> Both of them?
>> Just the half people cared
about.
>> If you build it, they will
rumble.
>> Build what?
>> A wrestling ring.
In my corn field.
I bought this place from Kevin
Costner.
Skeezy fella.
Used to [bleep] [bleep]'s wife.
Look it up.
If you build it, they will come.
>> I built it.
now what?
>> All right, that was just a
joke.
No, I'm kidding.
Let's go watch 'em rumble.
Just getting to the good part of
this book.
Ole got his revenge on Dusty.
>> When does it start?
>> Be patient.
Be patient.
>> Oh, my gosh.
They're coming out of the corn.
What?
It's Ravishing Rick Rude
and Doink the Clown!
Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe it.
The Junkyard Dog is back from
the dead.
>> All right, I can't see
anything.
Are these obstructed view seats
or something?
Literally nothing is happening.
>> I can't believe this.
The Junkyard Dog just reversed
the power bomb!
>> I honestly think you're
making this up just so I don't
get pissed that you destroyed
two acres of corn.
Hey, how's Miss Elizabeth's body
holding up in the afterlife?
>> She's frenching Ravishing
Rick Rude.
Macho Man's gonna be so mad.
>> Eh, she's a whore.
She's always been a whore.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, yeah!
Bam Bam Bigelow just got elbow
dropped by the Macho Man.
>> Can really attractive people
not see ghosts?
>> Did you see that clothesline?
>> I can't see anything!
>> Oh, my gosh, Captain Lou
Albano is beating up the
Ultimate Warrior.
>> Okay, yeah, now I know you're
nuts.
>> Here comes the Big Boss Man
Slam.
>> I see someone.
Oh, it's just Malakai.
Malakai, get back in the corn!
>> They're kicking the crap
out of Chris Benoit.
>> A little harder when it's not
children and women, right,
Chris?
>> You won't believe this.
>> You're right, I won't.
What?
>> They're all in big trouble
now.
It's the eighth wonder of the
world, Andre the Giant!
Oh, boy!
He's four feet taller than the
corn if he's an inch!
>> What does that even mean?
>> He's climbing over the top
rope.
Now he's choke slamming
everyone.
Andre the Giant's gonna win the
Royal Rumble!
[gasps]
>> What?
>> Owen Hart just fell from the
heavens and killed Andre the
Giant.
Now they're both dead.
Again.
>> All right, so it's over?
I wish Sting was dead, so you
would've been able to see him.
Now replant my corn.
>> That's right, Arn.
I was thumbing through your
stupid book!
Keep your friends close and your
enemies closer!
What'd you self publish that
pamphlet?
Yeah, I'm calling you out, Arn!